Good morning everybody.
I’m Judy Singer,
I'm the Senior Vice Provost for
Faculty Development
and Diversity,
And I want to welcome
everybody here
to a university conversation
about mentoring
We see this as a unique opportunity
to bring together,
several different types of
groups of people
who don’t normally cross paths.
So, one particular
feature of this event
is that it’s across the university
We have people from
the Longwood area
who are both medical school
and the school public health
who are here,
and we have people from all across
the Cambridge campus joining us.
This conversation was also designed
to be a cross-cohort,
so we have both distinguished
senior mentors
and senior faculty who
want to learn
more about mentoring
and what they can do,
as well as some tender
track faculty
who are hopefully,
willing to share with us
their perspectives
on what would be helpful.
One of the things you
learn when you
start to think about mentoring
is the people who want to be helpful
don’t actually know what it is
that they can be doing to be helpful
and we’re hoping that
this conversation will stimulate ideas.
I want to say a few words
about why we’re focusing on mentoring.
This is actually the first of three
faculty development events
we’re holding over the
next few weeks
The other two are focusing
on book publishing
and media training:
learning how to talk to reporters
and people in the media.
We’re starting out with mentoring
because we are using that to focus
on the renewed commitment
of the university
to a tenure track system
and that’s something that’s a C-change
from the old Harvard
I was at a conference last week
down in Washington
and I saw a faculty member
who is now at the
University of Michigan,
who used to be a faculty member
at one of our professional schools,
who we tried to keep but who left
And I asked how things were going
and whether we could possibly
lure him back
and he said, “Well, where
I am is much better.
It was much better for junior faculty."
And I said, "Well no, Harvard has a
tenure track system now."
And he said, "What happened
to the eight-year
Post Docs they used to give people?"
We actually see this as a commitment
to the development of people that we hire,
that we hope to be promoting up
through the ranks.
And we need mentoring programs
because if we actually commit to
this kind of system,
we need to make sure that our tenure track
faculty can succeed
as they move up the ladder.
In my own career,
mentoring has been keenly important.
In fact as I walk into the faculty club,
I am always reminded of
my first encouters here
which were breakfast
with my graduate school thesis adviser,
Fred Marstellar.
And we would meet for breakfast
in the main dining room
at the ungodly hour of seven o’clock,
which to me was like—
I coudn't believe it
But Fred would very kindly
take me aside
and sort of talk to me about
my own professional development.
when i was hired
I actually knew I didn’t want
to be a professor
because of the way I saw Junior Faculty
and the Harvard Statistics department
being treated.
In fact the department has
just tenured last year,
its first person from within
in about 45 years,
just to recognize the kind of C-change.
But I saw Junior Faculty
and they were treated like
rotating day laborers
and it just didn’t make a
very attractive career.
The reason I ended up going
into academia
was because of mentors for people
who took me aside
and said, “Judy, you’d be really
good at this.
You don’t really understand
as a graduate student
what life as a faculty member is like
and so why don’t you apply”
in fact for the only job I ever applied
was an Assistant Professor
at the Graduate School of Education,
where my faculty position is now.
And there too I was fortunate enough
to have mentors who really helped me
and helped me understand.
And that was at a time when there were
very few women at the university.
Pat Graham was my dean
and she was the first woman dean
at the university,
appointed in 1981 by
President Bach
She was the thirteenth female
tenured faculty member at the university.
I mean, people used to know their number,
just to put it in perspective.
And when she joined the faculty
and came to the faculty club,
she had to go in through back door
because that's where women went
I tell those anecdotes just to say
that this is a new Harvard,
or as Martin Minot said in a recent
interview in the New York Times
about Harvard five years
after Larry Summers infamous
comment on women and science:
“This is not your father’s Harvard.”
And what I hope today
is we can actually have a
conversation about
how Harvard can support all faculty
in their professional development.
So with that, I’m going to turn it
over to my colleague,
Ms. Cariaga-Lo, Assistant Provost for
Faculty Development and Diversity,
who’ll do some housekeeping matters
and also introduce our distinguished panel.
Thank you very much.
Good morning everyone
and thank you all for coming
this morning.
We are so delighted with with the response
that we got when we sent out
the mentoring invitation
In fact, the response was so large
that we were unfortunately unable
to meet everybody’s needs
and so we actually had to turn
away some people.
But we hope to have additional
conversations
around mentoring at the various
schools very soon.
Just a few housekeeping notes:
So, you all received a packet.
The green packets are actually
Sciences packets,
so the articles are slightly different.
The purple is a Humanities and
Social Sciences packet
and the only real difference is really
the research articles
that we’ve included in there
to help you think about mentoring
from the perspective of
your disciplines
and fields. In addition, in the packet,
we provided some tools
that we hope will help you think
about mentoring,
not just for faculty in your
department
but also thinking about mentoring
in different perspectives
and through various opportunities
that you might find yourself in,
whether it’s working with
young faculty
or working with trainees
or working with students
So, I hope that you find that useful.
In addition,
as you think about mentoring
in your departments,
we do hope that you will allow
us to assist you as needed.
If you are thinking about developing
mentoring programs
in particular for your tenure
track faculty,
we have some wonderful
experts in the room
and I hope that you will
use them today
but also beyond that,
to be in touch with them
as you begin to think about developing
mentoring programs for your faculty.
Today we are very honored actually,
to have in our midst leadership
from the schools,
four individuals who actually
have been instrumental
to developing mentoring activities
at the various schools.
And I am honored to have them
come with us today,
some of them just flying in early this
morning from Chicago,
John Reid and others
who are also just running in
and out of meetings.
So, we are grateful to them
for taking the time to come here.
Our four panelists this morning,
who will speak from the perspective
of leaderships
in the schools around mentoring are:
Cherry Murray,
Dean of Harvard University’s
School of Engineering
and Applied Sciences
and the John A
and Elizabeth Armstrong Professor
of Engineering and Applied Sciences,
Julio Frank, Dean
of the Faculty
and T&G Angelopoulos
Professor of Public Health
and International Development
at the Harvard School of Public Health;
Joan Reede, Dean of Diversity
and Community Partnership
and Associate Professor at the
Harvard Medical School,
as well as Associate Professor
of Society,
Human Development and Health
at the Harvard School of Public Health
and Michele Lamont, Robert I Goldman
Professor of European Studies
and Professor of Sociology and African and
African American Studies,
as well as the Senior Advisor
and Faculty Development
and Diversity in the Faculty of
Arts and Sciences.
Thank you all for coming today
and we look forward to hearing
your thoughts on mentoring.
So, we will start with Dean Murray
and then Dean Frenk
and Dean Reede and then
Professor Lamont
Sure. So, I’m glad to see so many people
here interested in mentoring.
So, I was asked by Judy to talk a little bit
about my own personal experiences
and what I’ve done at the School of
Engineering and Applied Sciences,
which we call SEAS.
So first off,
I’ve been here at Harvard
for exactly six months,
so I don’t know Harvard that much
but I’m learning a lot about it.
And I have been having lunches
with the tenure track faculty
at the School of Engineering
We’re a growing school
and so we actually are hiring quite a few—
by that I mean,
we have only 70 FTE faculty—
and we’re hiring in
proportion to that,
quite a few people.
And so Engineering is
moderately new at Harvard,
that is to say,
it’s been around for hundreds of years
but it's a brand new school since 2007
and so it’s the last school
and the first in 70 years
that is a new school in Harvard.
And so we’re kind of getting
ourselves together as:
what is this school going to be?
So, let me first talk a little bit about
my personal experience
with mentoring.
So, I went to MIT,
got a PhD in Physics
and was recruited by
Bell Laboratories
and went to Bell Laboratories
just immediately after
graduate school.
And my first week at
Bell Laboratories,
I had an anti-mentoring
experience.
Someone from the department
came in and said,
“So you’re here. What are
you going to do?”
And so I said, “Here’s the kind of
stuff I was planning on doing.
I’m going to set up these
experiments.”
This is what I told people.
And the reaction of this
person was,
“Well, you’re never going
to survive here.”
So, that was my anti-mentoring
experience,
which I did not consider
to be very positive.
and when I became
I got on the leadership council,
which is very much like the
faculty council here.
I actually went around to all
of the new members
ot technical staff in the
research area
and asked them,
"Would you like a mentor?"
And 100% of them,
whether they are male, female,
under-represented,
didn’t matter, said yes.
And so I set up a mentoring
program at Bell Labs
which actually worked quite well.
Then as I got up higher in
management there,
I was assigned a formal mentor
who was the head of a business unit,
which I found to be extremely useful
when I was a department head,
which is like the third
level of management
Bell Labs did not do very well
until we actually put in a mentoring
program for the young people
but by the time you got
in to management,
they did extremely well.
So when I arrived at Harvard,
I discovered that we did not have
a mentoring program.
That is to say we had an informal
mentoring program,
where the former dean had said,
“Why don’t you go mentor
this person too?”
But the person didn’t know
they were being mentored
and it was quite...
So, what I set up is mentoring
networks which is—
we don’t have departments
in the school
so I had to assign an associate dean
to each tenure track faculty member
so nobody fell between the cracks,
and then they are in charge of a
mentoring developmental
committee
So, we all sat together as
associate deans
and suggested names of people
for each of the tenure track faculty
and then the associate dean
sits with the tenure track faculty
member and asks,
“Which of these people
would you like?
Are you thinking of someone else
as your formal mentors?”
So, three or four people are
on this mentoring committee,
and I have a meeting every quarter
with the associate deans,
with the chairs of these mentoring
committees to see how
people are doing.
So Michele asked me today,
“How is this going?”
And actually it’s going very well
except some of the tenure track
faculty were on leave,
either maternity leave
or some other leave
and they kind of fell between
the cracks.
That is to say,
all of the associate deans
at the very beginning
went out when I asked them to,
to talk to their tenure
track faculty
but the ones who weren’t there
at the time,
they kind of forgot about it.
So, I reminded the associate
deans again.
And now I’m having lunches
with the tenure track faculty
and asking them how it’s going,
and I think it's going
a whole lot better.
So, I guess the story line about this
is keep following up
if you’re setting up a
mentoring program,
keep following up with
both the mentors
and the mentees to make sure
it’s working.
Thanks.
Good morning to everyone.
My name is Julio Frenk.
I have been Dean of the
Harvard School of
Public Health
for twice the amount
as Cherry,
for about a year.
So you have the table here
of new deans,
at least on this side of the table.
But thank you very much
for inviting me
because mentoring is really
a topic that is very,
very near and dear to
my heart,
probably stemming
from the opposite:
a very, very fundamental
mentoring relationship
I developed,
first as a graduate student
and then as a junior
faculty member
with Avedis Donabedian
who was actually a graduate
of the Harvard School of
Public Health
And I went to the
University of Michigan
to study with him
and under him
and then I joined the faculty
with him.
And I think it was probably
not just one of the most
informative
but one of the most
formative experiences
of my life.
So, I think having benefited
from what a good mentoring
relationship is,
I’m a strong believer in that,
because academia is
a highly competitive
environment
and it is not obvious,
even after having been
there in the student role,
how to navigate those waters
without the sort of very,
very personal guidance.
Fortunately, the Harvard School
of Public Health
has had a long tradition of
emphasizing mentoring,
particularly my predecessor
Bary Bloom already in the year 2000
fromed a committee to assess
junior faculty mentoring.
And based on the
recommendations
from that faculty committee,
each department was then
required to develop it's own
strong mentoring policy,
which included assigning
each new faculty member
a mentor at the time of
the faculty member’s
appointment.
So, the school in addition—
although it looks like a
play on words—
you have to monitor mentoring.
Monitoring mentoring
is a key aspect.
So, there is what is called
a bi-annual mentoring survey
and through that we’ve learned
that a lot of progress
has been made but also,
there’s a lot of
much more needs to be done.
So, since I began my tenure—
because I had the privilege
of spending the full term
of 2008 already being appointed
but not yet having taken office—
I spent those four months
coming every month for a week,
to Harvard.
And mentoring was one of the topics
that emerged right at the top
of my early conversations
with department chairs
and with faculty members.
So, I made this one of
my priorities
particularly because
the way I’ve expressed
not so much the vision
but the ambition for
the School of Public Health
is to make it the first school
of public health of the 21st century,
the first both in time and in quality.
and you can only build
the school of the 21st century
with the generation of the
21st century
and that generation
is the generation of
the junior faculty members.
So, the only way to be effective
in realizing that ambition
is to actually invest in
junior faculty.
So among other things,
we’ve established for
the first time,
an office of an associate dean
for research that funds
SEAT grants,
provide scientific
editorials report,
external review of
grant proposals
and a number of support mechanisms
for a school that's heavily
dependent on research
and where promotion is
heavily dependent
on research productivity.
Probably my diagnosis
is that a lot of progress has
been made
but the remaining challenge
is heterogeneity across
departments.
So, the quality of your
mentoring relationship
should not have such variation
because then also in the networks
of the faculty,
the realization of very
different experiences
is a factor in demoralizing
some people
that don’t get the quality
that they see peers getting.
So, trying to achieve
some uniformed standards-
high standards is one of
my priorities,
so some school-wide mentoring
guidelines have been established.
And under these new guidelines,
each new junior faculty member
meets with a chair of the department
soon after arriving at the school.
At that time, a primary mentor
is identified.
Sometimes there’s also a
secondary mentor.
The mentors meet with the mentees
at the beginning of their
appointment
and then at a minimum,
they have to meet
at the end of each academic year
to review academic progress
and plan for the next year.
So, there’s a formal structure
but I think it’s also very important
to stimulate informal
mentoring relationships.
So in a sense,
it’s a multi-tiered strategy
with primary,
secondary and informal mentors
and in addition,
members of the leadership
of the academic administration
of the school,
particularly the senior
associate dean
for faculty affairs
and the associate dean
for research that I just mentioned,
meet with the junior faculty
at critical points in their careers.
So, it’s this three layers of the chair,
the formal and informal mentors
and then the school-wide
academic leadership.
But let me end
because they did ask us to
talk a little bit
about personal experience.
And I thought what I would do—
and this would take literally a minute.
When my beloved mentor
Avedis Donabedian passed away
after a very, very productive
and rich life, I was—
having been his student
and pupil—
to speak at his memorial
and I reflected on the relationship.
So, let me quote two
paragraphs from—
just a very brief mention
to what I said there.
And this is what I said:
Ours, referring to Avedis
and me,
was the pragmatic
mentoring relationship.
In our age of mass
education,
the mentor has become an
endangered academic species.
A mentor teaches you
but is much more than a teacher.
A mentor befriends you
but is much more than a friend.
A mentor guides you
but is much more than a guide.
What a true mentor does
is one of the greatest gifts
of generosity.
He, I was talking about Avedis
but we would say
he’s or she sows in your mind
and in your soul,
the seeds that will
nourish intellect
and spirit for the rest of your life.
So to me, this is the nature
of the mentoring relationship.
And let’s not forget
where this word comes from.
It’s actually an individual--
a figure in Greek Mythology
(Mentor)
who is entrusted with the
care of Telemachus
when his father has to go to
the Trojan wars.
So, although in this marvelous
plasticity of the English language
we’ve turned it into a verb
and an adjective,
let us not forget that the root
of the word refers to an individual,
and it’s this personal dimension,
this very, very profound,
deep relationship that I think
holds both to the
enormous potential
and also the great rewards
of mentoring.
Thank you.
Good morning.
So like others,
I’ve been asked to give
both a personal perspective
but also part of a perspective
from Harvard Medical School.
And so I’ll say personally
in terms of mentoring,
as you look through the literature
and you hear people talk about it,
they talk about issues
such as matching on gender
and matching on race ethnicity
and how important
those things are.
And what I would say is,
is if I look at my career
and my progression
if I were to find the
perfect mentor
that was matched on all of
my dimensions,
the only person that could mentor me is me.
And so for me,
I have had multiple mentors.
The idea of a network of mentors
is the only way I have survived,
and they have crossed
race ethnicity,
and gender, and discipline.
They have been individuals—
and as you talked about
the anti-mentoring—
that have protected me
from what Bill Silan calls,
the dementors and
the tormentors
and they continued
as I moved forward in my career,
critical elements for
my success and my balance.
And those are the individuals
who early on,
when I was at
Harvard Medical School
and Harvard School of
Public Health
and my interests were
very different from others,
told me to pursue
my interests
and backed me in pursuing
and creating my own space
for what I thought was
important,
and actually showed me
that there was a value to
advancing academically.
Before then I had not thought that
there was any value to it
and it was my mentors
who told me that there was
and were able to show
me the way.
I want to give you an example
of some of the things
that we’ve actually done
at the medical school.
And the first begins with
everyone saying that mentoring
is critically important
but not really recognizing it
and our faculty affiliate
really wasn’t recognized.
So, in 1995 our office
established a mentoring award
for the school that has
grown over time.
It is an award that was
establish in 1995
but has grown
and since then,
over 3700 nominations
have come in
for close to 1200 individual
faculty members.
It’s grown from an
initial award
that was named the
Cliff Barger award
to having three categories
of Cliff Barger award
for those who have
been in service
for a minimum number
of years,
a final award for those
who have been in service
for more than 20 years,
and what we call a young
mentor award
for those who have been
in service for less than 10 years.
To date, there have been
122 awardees.
What I find important
about this
is when we did our new promotion criteria
for the school,
these awards were recognized
within the promotions.
And so how do you start to
recognize mentoring,
and recognizing the way
that it starts to show up
on individuals CVs,
it’s taken into consideration
for promotion,
recognized throughout
our environment.
Other ways in which it
has been recognized
include CHAD which is a consortium
or committee across the
Faculty Development
and Diversity offices
at the various Harvard
affiliated institutions
with the medical school.
And they actually offer
a mentoring course,
led by Jean Emmons
who is here,
who was a silent
mentoring awardee.
There is also a task force
on Faculty Development
and Diversity
that will be coming out
with a report in the
next few months
and one of the three
main committees
of this task force deals
with mentoring,
again chaired by
Jean Emmons.
When we look at
mentoring—
because I want to mention
some of the other people that are here—
and oftentimes,
we get an image of a sage,
white man with white hair
and blue eyes
and all the other kind of things
that go along with that.
And important part of this
is recognizing that mentoring
occurs all across our faculty.
And one of the people that
we have here
that I really want to point out
is Jessica Henderson Daniel,
who is the first woman
and the first person of color
to win the mentoring award
at Harvard Medical School
and recognizing it across the board.
And Jessica,
you should go like this…
So, there are many ways
I think in which
we are trying to
advance mentoring.
The last part is actually
taking from those individuals
who have won the
mentoring award,
and now there is a
council of mentors
that is actually meeting
and looking at
what is going on
with the mentoring in the school,
ways in which we can
improve mentoring
but it’s taken from the best
across our campus
and across disciplines.
Thank you.
Well, I was appointed
a year ago to this new role
as Faculty Advisor
on Faculty Development
and Diversity,
and one of the reasons
I agreed to do this
is because I thought
there was a really nice
theme in place
with many people committed
to creating cultural
change in FAS
and this is not a minor thing.
FAS is a very large part
of the University.
It’s 40% of the faculty
forty-two departments
and these departments
are very different in their culture.
Some of them have never promoted,
some of them have been
promoting regularly
over the last few years,
so it’s really a complex mosaic.
First my experience
with my own mentoring:
I’m Canadian,
I went to Paris as a
graduate student
at a very young age
and there was no mentoring.
It was a pure swim or sink system
and that was very difficult,
it taught me resilience.
And in 1983 I went to
Stanford as a Post Doc
and I discovered a word
that was totally unknown to me.
I felt those students were
unbelievably lucky,
privileged and also
they were getting extremely
good training.
Then in ’87 I was hired
at Princeton in Sociology
where I was for 15 years
before coming here in 2003.
And Princeton at the time
still had a system where
only one person in six
approximately,
got tenure and that was
also a little bit baptism by fire.
I really felt that they were
not taking very good care
of us and many,
many of my friends left
when we got tenure.
All my friends were
gone basically.
And then I came here in 2003.
My scholarship is on
Culture and Inequality.
I am presently working on
anti-racism in France and the US,
I really have a long-term commitment
to trying to understand
how collective definitions
of worth influence
for production of inequality,
so my involvement in this
is very much driven by
my own scholarship.
I also happen to have a significant other
who also studies diversity.
And actually in the Globe
this weekend,
there was a big article
on his work
which basically shows that he
studied 800 corporations
looking at which one have been
most successful at
favoring diversity.
And he finds that what is
most effective is structural change:
that is appointing people
who actually have as a responsibility
or appointing task force
who are in charge of
overseeing diversification
and also using carrots
and stick to really create change.
And mentoring is a very
big part of the equation.
So, with all this background—
my predecessor Liza Martin had
resigned in 2005,
after having created a
mentoring program
where women were matched—
only junior tenure track faculty—
were matched with mentors
in other departments,
which was a very good idea,
because you can actually
ask advice to people
who will not be involved
in your promotion
where you can look
more vulnerable
than the people who will be one
day be in charge
with looking at your work.
Departments were asking FAS
to report on their
mentoring activities
but there was just an enormous amount
of informal mentoring occurring.
And the literature shows us
that informal mentoring
mostly benefits people
who are entitled and many,
many people did not
benefit from it.
So, the idea was really
to create a new system
that was launched this fall,
where we’re asking
both departments
and individuals to
create mentoring plans.
And actually, we don’t
use the word mentoring,
we use the word
development network,
drawing on the work of David Thomas
who is an expert
on the question,
who works in the
Business School
and Monica Higgins
who works in the
School of Education.
And the idea is that
tenure track faculty
create a network of people
with multiple nodes
that will answer various needs
and the needs that are evolving
as they move through the
tenure track system.
And the word mentoring itself
is not that great a word
because in fact,
what most people are seeking
is intellectual exchange
that is the ability to get
people to read their work.
When we work in my department
to launch
our mentoring plan this fall,
this is what they want.
They know that the faculty
are unbelievably busy
but they want us to really understand
that we’re supposed to set aside
few days a year to read manuscript
and give them feedbacks
so that they will be able
to improve their work
on which they will be judged
when they come up for tenure.
So, departments had until March 1st
to turn in their mentoring plans
and many of them have.
I'm very pleased.
The cultural change is very—
the purpose in fact is not
to create these mentoring plan.
It’s really to create a cultural change.
And creating a structure in itself
is probably the easiest
part of the challenge.
What will be much more
of a challenge
will be to monitor in a year,
what has been happening.
And there, I’m certainly going to
email my co-panelists
to learn more about
the tools that they have
put in place.
I think that at Harvard,
where there’s such a
strong culture of excellence,
diversity is often viewed
as a pollutant
or even claiming aid-help
is viewed as a pollutant
because we all are supposed
to be so talented
that the cream will
rise naturally.
Well in fact everyone who
gets tenure
gets a lot of help:
they get their colleagues
to read their work,
they present their work
at colloquiam, et cetera.
So, the idea is that
to acknowledge that
getting help
is crucial to the raising
of the cream
but we want more of an
even playing field
where more people
get the help
that they need
to become all they can be.
And Harvard is I think,
a little bit—
if we think of what’s
happening at
Stanford or at Yale
our peer institutions are
fully engaged in this.
Stanford has its motto:
Diversity and Excellence
Together.
And we are very much
moving in the same direction
though FAS made a
very important statement
last week to this effect.
So, I think that
a lot of people are pushing
in the same direction
and I’m personally
quite optimistic
for the future.
Thank you.
Panelists,
we are in fact—
as an FYI—
we are in fact
videotaping this section
of this event.
And so we hope
to be able to have your faces
on our website soon,
so that others
who are not able to attend
can be guided by your wisdom.
So, thank you.
We are privileged on many
fronts here at Harvard
but I think that our human capital
at Harvard is unsurpassed
and we do indeed stand
on the shoulders of many giants here.
And often, we don’t recognize
how they profoundly change our lives
and how they profoundly
change our academic community.
So, today we wanted to be
able to acknowledge
some of these individuals,
and I hope that we can
do more of this,
as Joan had mentioned,
we can do more to recognize
the mentors
and those who support us-
those who help us through
the difficult challenges ahead
as we try to develop careers
here at Harvard.
So, I would like to have
Professor Scott Edwards—
as I call your name,
if you could please stand
in the front
so that we may embarrass
you further.
Professor Scott Edwards,
Professor Jean Emmons,
Professor David Golan,
Professor Virginie Greene,
Professor Ichiro Kawachi,
Professor Michele Lamont,
Professor Everett Mendelsohn,
Professor Joan Reede
and Professor
Marianne Wessling-Resnick.
For many years
these individuals have toiled
at many levels to support
mentoring,
not just in their schools
but in the University.
Some of them have established
awards to honor those colleagues
who have done mentoring
in their departments
and in their schools.
Others have simply
developed their own
informal mentoring programs
without virtue of resources
and often at the expense of their
own personal scholarship.
So, we are very grateful to them
for the work that they do
and I hope that you will enjoy
meeting them
in your discussion groups
because they will serve as guides,
as you think about the questions
that we have posed for
these discussion groups.
So, on behalf of the university,
we thank you for your
profound contributions to mentoring
and hope that we can gain insights
and guidance from you
in the years ahead,
as we think about mentoring
in the academy.
Let’s give them
a warm round of applause.
So, we keep on having to
cut off the conversation,
but that the conversations
want to continue
I take as a very good sign.
And in particular,
the cross-schools conversations
and the cross-cohort conversations
are very eye-opening in some cases
with some concrete ideas
about things that we might
be able to try
in our own environments
and in some cases
some very challenging
problems to address.
I have the pleasure now
of introducing our Provost,
Steve Hyman
who is going to share with you
some University perspectives
on mentoring.
So, please join me in
welcoming, Steve.
Thank you.
Let me start by
thanking you,
Judy and Lisa
and the staff of your office
and the Bach Center
for organizing this very,
very important event.
And let me thank
in absentia those deans
who either have been here
or will be here later
because a high-level
commitment is necessary
to this activity.
Those of you,
whether you are tenure
track faculty
or people who have leapt over
that hurdle at some time
in the past,
recognize the importance
of mentoring
and at the same time,
recognize that it is
often thankless
and that the rewards have
to be internal
because you know you’ve
done the right thing.
As a university,
we often don’t find adequate
ways to thank people
for their extraordinary efforts,
for their citizenship,
for their caring.
At least at a time of
famine and dirt,
at least we have
muffins for you
and unhealthy things
like bacon to express our thanks.
But in all seriousness,
this is such an important area
for the University.
And before I launch
into my remarks,
I want to particularly recognize
some of you here
who have won mentoring awards
and I’ve seen some of
you already:
Everett Mendelsohn
from Arts and Sciences,
Jean Emmons from HMS,
Ichiro Kawachi
from Public Health,
Marianne Wessling-Resnick
Scott Edwards
who I saw from Arts and Sciences
and Professor Virginie Greene
from FAS,
who I also saw a few
minutes ago.
You are—and I hope
I’m not missing other names
but you are really exemplars.
I also again, want to thank
members of the leadership team
and tenured faculty
who are here to talk about this
Although the president
of the university
is the person
who actually confers tenure,
I chair half of the tenure cases
except for the medical school,
where actually I’m the last
signature on all of them.
I mean, the good news is
that at this last step of the ad hoc
the success rate is very, very high.
But all too often,
we see people for whom the case is
closer than it should be,
despite their brilliance
and their effort and sometimes,
people who really should have
made it don’t make it.
And in some sense
there are many reasons for
this but often,
I thought to myself
after a difficult case,
that had there only been
the right kind of mentoring,
this would have had a
different outcome.
And often, people are left to
fend for themselves
or they have sort of glancing,
intermittent mentorship
and also from the point of view
of the mentors.
It’s important to engage in
groups like this
and stay up-to-date
and understand
what the different schools
are looking for because—
for example in many other schools,
Arts and Sciences in particular,
teaching which at one time
was considered to be something
that you had to do
but it wasn’t worth all
that much
is now an important part
of tenure cases,
we just saw a new criteria
from the School of
Public Health
that made teaching important.
So, each school has a different
culture and different weights.
And while tenure track faculty
shouldn’t enslave their energies
and their interests to some plan
for what it takes to achieve tenure,
obviously people have
to follow their loves
and their intellectual leads.
Still, it is so important
that people understand
the system
and have the kind of helpful
engagement in every stage
so that we can achieve
what we want
which is the success of all
of our tenure track faculty.
So in that sense,
I’m really happy to see
this room full,
and the only thing
I could wish for is to see many,
many more rooms full.
Because in the end,
we have committed ourselves
as a University increasingly
to a tenure track system
or in some of the
professional schools,
something like that
without a name.
And what that really means
is that we want to be committed
to our tenure track faculty,
we want to get them through
these set of processes.
But this is not a matter of magic,
this is a matter of effort
and engagement
where mentoring is
particularly important.
And I think many of us
think back to the importance
of senior faculty
and mentors in our own careers
and it’s something though
that just has not been
adequately institutionalized.
And so I commend everybody
for being here.
I wish you all a productive
and useful day
and I hope—
especially those of you
who are already tenured—
I was told it’s no longer PC
to talk about senior and junior faculty.
But those of you who
are senior faculty,
I hope you’ll be evangelists
for the importance of mentoring
in your schools
because frankly
as I said at the outset,
this is not enough recognized
or enough rewarded
but it is absolutely critical
if we are going to
succeed as a University
in one of our most important goals,
which is to help our tenure track
faculty make it over this bar
and permanently join
our community.
So, thank you very, very much.
Well, I was in a group
that included senior faculty
and tenure track faculty
in the Social Sciences
and the Humanities
but across different schools
in the Kennedy School FAS
and the Harvard School
of Public Health
and the medical school,
and we had a really interesting
conversation,
a troubling one too.
Because some of the tenure track
faculty who were there—
I would say three of them—
described context
where they were really caught
between two chairs,
in the sense of having
an appointment in a school
where the discipline is
not marginalized
but not dominant discipline,
what path to follow
when basically your chair
is very busy
and is not immediately
available to give you feedback
about whether you should
publish in your own field
or publish for your school.
Another case where a department
hasn’t promoted since 1950
and the person basically,
doesn’t know if his FTE will be
in one department or another,
another case where the
output of the scholar
is a very unconventional one
by Harvard’s criteria.
So for me in my role,
I’m thinking we really need
a kind ombudsperson
to whom people could go
and raise a red flag early on
to try to understand better,
the criteria by which they
are going to be evaluated.
A second issue that was raised
is that of variation in the faculty
in how much weight they put on
various criteria of publication:
what kind of publication
books versus articles,
service and teaching.
And Judy Singer who was there,
mentioned an experiment
they did in the School of Ed,
where they asked all the faculty
to attribute 100 points to
the various dimensions
they used while looking
at their file.
And they found it was a
very teachable moment
when the results
were distributed and
the faculty came to
the realization
of how much difference
there was in how much weight
they put on the various criteria,
which really made me think
about the importance
of spending much more time
among the senior faculty,
thinking much more
explicitly than we do,
about what do we do
when we are evaluating.
We have now in Affairs,
a situation where some departments
have never promoted,
others have promoted
regularly.
And I think among the
more senior faculty
who have been here
for 40 years
and those who have come
over the last 10 years,
there are different expectations
about what a Harvard
faculty should be
and this really needs to be
talked about
much more explicitly.
So, that’s a second central
theme in our conversation.
A third one was
how to find good mentors.
Members of our group
mentioned the importance of gossip
and of hanging out in hallways,
and really how much good ideas
come at the most unexpected time.
... who was
trained in New Zealand
was regretting the good habit
of drinking tea together
three times a day for
15 minutes,
so we concluded,
I think we should just institute
that here in all schools.
That’s basically what came up.
I don’t know if any of our
group member
would like to highlight
any other point
that I did not mention…No.
So, we had a very active
discussion,
raising first the fact that there
are very different rules
and ways of looking at
"ladder faculty"
so that we didn’t necessarily share
a common language
from the medical school,
the hospitals, FAS,
the School of Public Health
and therefore as mentoring
goes forward
at Harvard overall
and to make sure that
the language is more global
and more really
accepting of the entire group.
And so just in terms of
the common language,
the issues of promotion
versus career satisfaction
and really accepting
some heterogeneity
in the definition of
what we want for mentoring.
It was clear that there should
be expectations Harvard wide,
of a change of culture
that mentoring was important
across all career trajectories.
A lot of interest in mentor
and mentee training,
so that again there was
more uniformity
both in our senior faculty of
knowing how to really
effectively mentor
but for our junior faculty
to have more information
on how to be  a great mentor
and what to expect.
And this could be in the form of
part of the boot camp
that’s part of—
apparently when the new faculty
come to FAS
and some other areas,
perhaps orientation at the hospitals
so that there’s sort of a module
that explains some of the ways
that one can think about
being a mentee.
The other issue is to certainly
leverage the infrastructure
of already the hospitals,
the departments, et cetera
and just to make it part of the
faculty discussions,
part of sort of every area,
whether it’s a faculty meeting,
perhaps you can do
mentor training
because the faculty are already
there at the faculty meeting
and they’re not likely to show
up at other places sometimes.
And then we talked about
some of the various models
which could be junior faculty
doing peer mentoring.
There could be a senior person
there or not there,
so it could serve a
networking focus
and also to help the junior
faculty develop skills.
There was a sense that many of the
junior faculty were told,
“Well, don’t mentor anyone because
that will ruin your own career.”
And so we’re giving sort of
an early message
and that’s not really what we want
to develop in the long run.
And then Jessica brought
up some issues
around serial mentoring.
You may think of it from the
adolescent point of view,
which is where I think of it,
which is serial monogamy.
But certainly, to think
about the fact that
one needs developmental networks
that Kathy Graham
and David Thomas and
Monica Higgins
and others have really
thought about
in terms of a more broad-based
issue for our faculty.
What’s interesting is the
word Career Mentors
is used very differently.
In some places it’s the scholarly
or research mentoring
and in other places it’s somebody
worrying about your career,
who’s not your division chief.
So, I think if we can develop
some common terminology,
at least when we have
these meetings
we’ll know what each one
is talking about.
But it was a very good
discussion.
We’d still be there in the living room
if you hadn’t brought us
back upstairs.
So, thank you.
I need to be mentored in a
most effective way
to weave from back
to front
and take the least
amount of time.
We had a very good
discussion.
We had representatives
from FAS,
from Harvard School of
Public Health
and the medical school.
And from the medical school,
from both hospital
and the medical school itself.
And I’m going to go over
lots of discussion,
lots of ideas thrown out.
But going down across
the questions
in terms of what are some of
the critical needs.
Some of the areas that were
discussed were:
increasing knowledge
about multiple career paths
so that there’s not only
one path;
being able to help people
with their transitions;
helping and encouraging
individuals to take risk
and understanding that
advancement requires risk;
this idea that all that we’re
focusing now on
are those who are on the ladder
and understanding
that we need
the mentoring across
the spectrum,
and that many of the people
at the early stages of the ladder
transitioning to more
senior positions
and they need that same kind
of advice and mentoring.
So, keeping something in
place across the spectrum.
There needs to be a mechanism
for acknowledging
and dealing with
anti-mentoring.
And the other one was:
the mentees and what’s
needed for them
is this network of those both
inside and outside.
So, much of our focus today
has been on the mentoring within
our institution but equally,
there’s a need to create
the networks
and the supports outside
of our institutions.
In terms of some of the roles
and responsibilities for mentors
and mentees:
with regard to the mentors,
they talked about a
cultural competence
and a holistic approach;
knowledge for the
mentor themselves,
that you just don’t
need one mentor
but you need multiple mentors,
and this issue of it being quality
and not quantity in terms
of the mentor.
And for the mentees:
this idea of paying it forward
at all levels,
that someone can mentor
someone else
who is coming behind them.
In terms of some of the
policies and practices,
we talked about something
called mentor domains.
Somebody mentioned
mentor domains
and they talked about four
domains practice
or what I call part of the
scholarship or discipline;
second being promotion
and understanding the system there;
the third academic productivity
and the fourth, environmental
and things such as work
life balance.
The other component dealt with
more of the institutional aspects
and what institutions or
departments could do.
We talked about ways in
which departments
or institutions could support
the mentoring
by offering other programs.
It was mentioned from the
Psychiatry Department
where these writing seminars
and what they call
charisma conferences.
We also talked about faculty
development sessions.
It was mentioned that there was a
need for mechanisms
to make matches for
individuals
to be more aware of who’s in
the environment
and who may be able to
help them.
And Harvard School of
Public Health
talked about their going to
put in a mentor registry.
We talked about the need for
rewards or rewards for
mentoring;
having mentoring
resources available,
something that might
be online;
the training and teaching
of mentors.
And then they talked about—
and it was alluded it
to an ombuds—
somebody early on alluded
but it was stated that in
and of itself would
not be adequate.
Anybody from our group
that has other things,
that I might have left out?
Thank you.